une ville associée à la lutte pour les
droits civiques ou Martin Luther King a
été emprisonné dans les années 60
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les touristes se recueillent
devant des monuments en hommage à cette
époque
pour d'autres le combat se poursuit oui
un siège au Sénat de l'Alabama mais à
quelques jours des élections elle
concentre surtout ses efforts sur un
référendum pour changer la constitution
de son état
nous devons enlever le vocabulaire
raciste de notre Constitution
explique-t-elle ce que America veut
surtout c'est d'abolir formellement
l'esclavage pour tous les résidents de
l'Alabama y compris pour les personnes
incarcérées qui font pour l'instant
figure d'exception et
c'est une exception qu'on a gardé pour
maintenir l'accès à du travail gratuit
même après l'abolition de l'esclavage
déplore l'avocate
un constat que partage ce juriste qui
voit dans la modification de la
Constitution un
étudie pour devenir Barbière dans
quelques mois elle gagnera un salaire
qui devrait lui permettre de subvenir à
ses besoins contrairement à sa réalité
lorsqu'elle était en prison et qu'elle
travaillait sans être rémunéré
de 18 ans pour meurtre n'hésite pas à
qualifier le travail carcéral
d'esclavage
son fils est incarcéré depuis 27 ans
pour un crime qu'il a commis lorsqu'il
était adolescent ces chances de remise
en liberté sont minimes et pendant qu'il
est derrière les barreaux Robert gagne
un salaire dérisoire
la question du travail carcéral revient
souvent aux Etats-Unis l'été dernier les
détenus qui combattaient les feux de
forêt en Californie n'étaient payés que
quelques dollars par jour on accusait
alors les gouvernements d'abuser de ces
personnes incarcérées dans un pays où
les prisons sont souvent des entreprises
à but lucratifs le nombre de détenus en
Alabama a explosé dans les quatre
dernières années depuis que l'État
républicain a resserré les règles pour
obtenir une libération conditionnelle en
2018 54% des demandes étaient acceptées
un chiffre qui a maintenant chuté
environ 15%. les résultats les prisons
n'ont jamais été aussi pleines et les
conditions de détention se détériorent
ici sur les réseaux sociaux des vidéos
tournées clandestinement montre la
gravité de la situation dans les prisons
surpeuplées violences insalubrité des
conditions que le gouvernement fédérales
a qualifié digne humaine
j'ai très peur pour mon mari confie
Diane cordwell qui a organisé des grèves
de détenus dans les prisons pour
améliorer les conditions
on fait de la politique sur le dos des
gens déplore Véronica Johnson une
activiste qui milite pour une réforme en
profondeur du système pénal
mais les changements tarde à venir la
là-bas est après tout un état
conservateur
ultra religieux où les républicains
disposent d'une majorité écrasante tant
au Congrès qu'au Sénat et en période
électorale rares sont les politiciens
qui veulent avoir l'air laxiste en
matière de crime
ils veulent construire des prisons sur
d'anciens champs de coton soupir
Veronica qui rappelle que les personnes
noires sont sur représentées dans le
système carcéral appellation
ne voteront pas pour des réformes qui
désengorgeraient les prisons mais sa
proposition d'amendement constitutionnel
a tout de même reçu l'appui de la
législature un rarement de
transpartisannerie dans une Amérique de
plus en plus polarisée
bol et les droits civiques on a une
chance d'être connu pour quelque chose
d'autre
[Musique]
c'est fait une semaine de match à
burmingham et si les élections de
mi-mandat semblent bien loin des
préoccupations difficiles de savoir si
les électeurs voteront en grand nombre
pour changer leur constitution abolir
l'esclavage une fois pour toute un pas
de plus vers l'égalité dans une lutte
qui est loin d'être terminée